[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Are you looking
to build and showcase
your Cloud skills?
Want an easy way
to show them off?
You can now earn skill
badges from Google Cloud
to demonstrate your
growing Cloud competencies.
Here's how it works.
First, you need to join the
Google Cloud skills challenge.
This gives you 30 days of free
access to Google Cloud labs.
Then choose the track you're
interested in and get started.
Each track has a number of
skill badges up for grabs.
To earn a badge,
you'll need to complete
a series of Google Cloud labs.
Then you'll need to pass a
final challenge lab designed
to test your skills.
Once you've earned the badge,
showcase what you've learned.
You could add it to your resume
and share it with your network.
Ready to go?
Join the Google Cloud
skills challenge today,
and start earning
your skill badges.
[MUSIC PLAYING]